[Music]
you don't have to quit your job you can
find a half hour a day and even if you
think you can't find a half hour day you
can I'm not one of those people says you
don't need sleep like you definitely
need to sleep but you don't need the
extra hour online you don't need the
time playing a video game
the time you're gonna get in your car
drive to Starbucks drive to wherever
else that's 20 minutes that you could
sit and write something and if writing
is not your thing as cinemates you could
be taking photographs or that's 20
minutes that you could be working there
are 20 minutes in the day and those 20
minutes add up it's much easier to say I
can't find the time then I'm scared I
won't be any good that's Brian Koppelman
and this is the rich hall podcast
[Music]
the rich roll podcast hey everybody how
you guys doing what's happening my name
is rich roll I'm your host this is my
podcast welcome got Brian Koppelman on
the show today very excited producer
director screenwriter for music biz
executive you know this guy right he's
the mind a co-writer behind some
absolutely iconic films films like
rounders like Ocean's thirteen but he is
perhaps best known as the co-creator
along with his longtime co-writer and
best friend David Levine of the hit show
billions on Showtime which I don't know
about you but I absolutely love along
with this podcast the moment where he
has these amazing long-form
conversations with all manner of
successful creative people about the
pivotal moments that fueled their
fascinating careers brian is a guy I've
been falling for a long time he's an
incredibly prolific artist as well as
this amazingly generous source of
guidance and inspiration to the creative
community at large he's a guy who has
inspired my own creative endeavors in so
many ways so how does he do it how does
he manage it all how does he maintain
such a high level of consistently great
output and what can we learn where can
we learn about creativity what can we
glean from Brian's example his habits
his practices that can inform how we
think about ourselves as creative beings
in our own unique creative expression I
love this guy
and I'm just so excited that he agreed
to do the show when I was in New York
City the other month and there's a lot
that fascinates me about him how we
discovered Tracy Chapman and helped her
get her first record deal when he was
still in college how he walked away from
a very successful secure career in the
music business to pursue his dream of
being a writer
his love for and his dedication to his
craft the persistence that he
demonstrated to become successful and
how Tony Robbins and Julia Cameron
really changed his life we talked about
the many habits that he credits to his
long-term success
like daily meditation journaling the
artists way Julia Cameron's amazing book
and Brian's is really a story of someone
who was always creative but never really
thought of himself as an artist and then
the path that he blazes to make this
dream a reality
and then the generosity with which he
shares his experience what works what
doesn't and why to help all of us live
more fully and creatively expressed so
this is a conversation about nurturing
that inner voice about confronting and
overcoming negative self-talk and giving
yourself permission to do the work that
you want to do because in my opinion at
least the world is a better place when
we are living more fully expressed more
creatively expressed lives final note
season for billions returns to Showtime
on March 17th which I'm super excited
about season 3 he was absolutely insane
so if you're new to this show trust me
this is appointment viewing so get
caught up and with that I'll let the
master storyteller do the rest of the
storytelling so this is me and Brian
Koppelman
[Music]
you know you're about to get out the
door and then you get the call that you
don't have to but the truth is it is fun
appearing on a podcast where you know
the host has a clear objective a point
of view and a reason for doing the show
so this is you know fun for me I'm close
well I appreciate you doing it you're a
busy man you're wearing a lot of hats
these days and there's lots of Brian
Koppelman I want to explore the
screenwriter the dad the meditator the
morning routine guy the mentor which is
one of my favorite brian's and I love
you when you're with Bill Simmons too
you guys just have great and I love you
together so yeah I love listening to you
in that context and you're able to
vacillate between all these different
worlds from sports to entertainment to
music like you really have experience
and know your [ __ ] in so many arenas but
I think the thing that that draws me the
most to you beyond the amazing you know
work that you put out and share with the
world is is this mentorship role like
you've really made yourself available to
the creative community to be in
encouraging presence for those that have
a creative spark and are challenged in
kind of bringing it to life so I'm
interested in like how you kind of
matured into this role well I have a
great catholicity of interest I always
have but it's always been centered
around curiosity and obsession and so I
mean in the case of Bill Simmons he and
I've known each other 20 years yeah and
so that's a very easy and fun sort of
exchange and we we met and at this
intersection of entertainment and sports
in a way because our first movie
rounders was in some ways a sports movie
it had a lot of sports references and
Simmons used it to talk about basketball
and that's what we came together and I'm
thrilled to know that you're following
the work that I'm doing that that
closely man and I think that there's
something kindred in what you do and
what I do but it goes back to the fact
that when I was younger the Santee
answered your question which is why am I
so available to people and why
am i engaged and why do I become
animated by helping people breakthrough
creative blocks by helping people figure
out how to get to the core of what they
want to do and then to try to help them
do it and of course um I am NOT someone
who makes any money doing that I do it
completely pro bono uh really made you a
media presence though you know unlike
your writing partner David who's who's
you know he's not a media presence in
the way that you are sure I mean that
just breaks down to our personalities in
a way and what were each wedding what
were each most engaged by but but it
also I think ties into this which is
that David didn't have similar create a
block when he was young he didn't have a
problem or not the same kind of problem
figuring out that he wanted to be a
creative person and he didn't have a
kind of problem I did reconciling the
feeling in me that I was trying to get
out with my own perception of myself as
somebody who wasn't an artist who wasn't
one of the anointed people who wasn't
chosen or picked to be an artist I know
I I knew I was a smart person I knew
that I had great verbal dexterity I knew
I had certain skills but I didn't feel
and I knew I had a deep well a feeling
that I was trying to communicate I knew
when I was really excited about
something I wanted to share it I wanted
to find out everything about it I wanted
to find out what was special about it
and I wanted to go all the way into that
world and explore it and I knew I wanted
to find a way to write about it until
stories about it mm-hmm but I had an
incredibly difficult time putting myself
in a lane that said artists creative
person someone allowed to think of
themselves as a storyteller and so
because I was so jammed up and because I
was so miserable despite having success
um and some of this comes back as it
often does for all of us comes back to a
childhood where I was that kid who was
always told you're so smart why are you
so stupid and not by my parents who were
incredibly supportive but by the school
that I went to and and my own inability
to see to sort of solve that chucks
position for myself I couldn't reconcile
it either so it wasn't just that the
teachers couldn't reconcile it
I couldn't reconcile it you know and I
would look at some of the other kids
even as we're going up in high school
and doing the plays and they just seemed
like they had a kind of magic that I
didn't drive right right and because of
that when I finally did figure it all
out for myself or begin to figure it out
I felt so much more free and I'm happy
to tell you how that all happened but I
felt so much more free and so much more
like myself that if I can find a way to
help somebody get that feeling I want to
do it so if I can give him practical
tips you know I started doing this stuff
of trying to guide people by telling
them that most people hold themselves
out as experts work on people con men
usually sometimes con women and because
it bothered me to see aspirants give
their money when and very limited money
to suppose it gurus of screenwriting
good night the screen right the
ecosystem of instructors and so-called
gurus who are gonna tell you the secret
exactly no one else will tell you yeah I
felt so close to a kind of death I was
never a suicidal person and I was never
gonna die of misery I was but you know I
I've said before and I truly believe
that when a creative impulse dies it's
like any other kind of death and as
toxicity associated with it and Amy and
I had just had our first child I was 30
years old I was in a job where I was
making a good living and I was
successful at it
in by most metrics but I was not happy
and I finally got to this breaking point
because our our first kid was born and I
realized I didn't know how to be a good
parent if I wasn't if I become bitter I
wouldn't be a good parent and if I
allowed this creative impulse to die the
toxicity would leech out onto the people
that I loved
and that more than anything is what made
me finally get to the breaking point of
saying I have to change my behavior I
have to find a way to believe I can do
this work I have to start doing the work
and by figuring out how to break through
and get there made a gigantic difference
in yeah but there was a tremendous
amount of self-awareness around that
when you made that decision right so
like planting a flag a little bit
earlier when you're this creative kid
who feels like he you know can't bring
expression to this because it's not
allowed or this is not the trajectory
that you're on or these are not the
signals that are being reinforced in
your schooling etc I mean what was it
like at that time like what was the
awareness level at that time in terms of
when I was young yeah like you're you
know it's weird because I was also a I
loved to play sports mm-hmm and I wasn't
an athlete like you I wasn't a
world-class athlete but I played varsity
sports you know and I wasn't again not
great at it but I've coordinated and I
could play sports and I loved sports I
would do all the plays I would assist in
Toorak plays I even directed a play and
my a junior year of high school the one
kid got picked to direct the play I got
picked to it I didn't know that so you
were doing the thing I was doing those
things but didn't say it it didn't in
doing those things I would be the third
lead in the show I would direct the
thing because I I could you know I knew
how to talk to the actors in a way who
were gonna be really good at doing it I
had assistant directed and like put in
the time but my self-conception was that
like well I'm not really gonna be able
to do that that's not a valid and career
church and I think I I know that I had
ADHD in a way that it was back then was
really not diagnosed I'm 52 years old so
I grew up in the late 70s and 80s I went
to college in 84 graduating 88 so my
inability to complete work I always know
I could write a paragraph that would
make you laugh or feel scare I could
write a paragraph that would kind of
dazzle you but I couldn't write two
paragraphs or if I could write two I
couldn't turn in the paper my last
semester college I had seven incompletes
that I had to solve in order to graduate
and it wasn't willful man and this is
what was the torture of it was it was
the books if something for a person who
really has ADHD the most painful feeling
you know then something bad happen to
someone you love is boredom boredom is
not the way it is to most people to
people who
of real attention stuff and so a book or
an assignment that was like a book that
was poorly written or that was about
something that wasn't completely
captivating to me I couldn't read it the
book felt radioactive I could in college
I started to understand how to get
around that how to manage it a little
bit meaning I started to not feel as bad
about myself but when I was young it
felt terrible about myself and I felt I
was lazy and a lot of my life was about
later well I went to law school at night
ostensibly because I wanted to practice
civil rights law but in the end what I
realized I went to prove to myself that
I could do the work right yeah I can I
can relate to that did the same thing
not at night but that whole law school
trajectory yeah
but meanwhile your this this successful
music industry executive right like I
read that you discovered Tracy Chapman
like I did that's true
well yeah like nothing's ever simple
right sorry and I hadn't read Viktor
Frankl then I didn't understand the way
in which we have to learn to control our
own emotions then so I was prisoner to
my emotions in a certain way and I was
so yes I had the ability I was
successful at doing that and I had
wanted to do it a lot of my life and I
don't I've told the Tracy Chapman story
on plenty of times on my own podcast or
other people's but the shortest version
of it is I was one of the leaders on
campus of the anti-apartheid Pro
divestment movement and through that saw
Tracy playing my father was in the
record business so I knew about that
business and then I said about trying to
get Tracy record deal and produced her
demos and executive produced her first
album along with a guy named John Rubin
and that that all happened and it was
incredible but I was spat out of that at
the end of college having done that her
album was number one in August of the
year I graduated college to graduate in
April the album's earn may the album's
number one in August I'm working at
Elektra Records and suddenly that's what
I am without the normal few years after
college where you
to figure out right it's this really
what I'm supposed to I was lying town I
was able to do that job but but I was
also not the perfect person to do it I
wasn't the best person to do it my
kinship with what the artists did well
twinned with my even unknown to me
desire to be the one doing the art made
the whole thing really frayed it and the
big moment so we all have a few of these
moments in our lives reg where we
something happens that makes us look at
where we are where we plotted on the
graph and one of those was my whole life
the things that I loved so much were
music books movies comedy sports and I
would dive all the way in you know as
you see if you follow me on Twitter or
you see here me on other podcasts I'll
talk about all those things a lot and oh
you know I'll go very deep on those
things because of how obsessed I was but
one of the the sort of hallmarks of the
way that would express itself was I
always loved to share these obsessions
and when I would hear a great piece of
music all I wanted to do is tell all my
friends right when you're young 18 19 20
nothing moves you more than a song can
sort of take you to a place different
than any other art form I was in the
record business and I was it was 1993
and the Counting Crows August and
everything after came out and sorry the
album didn't come out what happened was
a guy in an office near me had gotten a
demo tape and called me into his office
and said come listen to this thing and
it was played me around here mm-hmm
and upon hearing it instead of being
filled with joy at because I instantly
knew how great it was I knew they would
be huge I knew this was a world-class
songwriter
once at every 10-year kind of talent I
was filled with rage that someone had
heard it before me I was filled with
jealousy competitive and staying to
hatred yes and but I I went home that
night and Amy and I had just gotten
married and I I I knew it so I I was
able to say the strangest thing happened
I heard this thing and I became at the
exact person I never wanted to be yeah
and so
that was like one of the sort of markers
for me that was another three years
before three or four years before I in
earnest started riding rounders with
David but that was one of the moments
where I realized okay Brian you are not
in a unified place right now you're not
comfortable in your own skin you're not
doing what you're supposed to be doing
because your reaction was 180 degrees
from what the best version of you should
be and that I was able somehow to see
that even and I could see it before
changing my behavior so I didn't quit my
job and I didn't start writing but I did
have a moment of a dawning of a reality
and then you know what do we do we show
up for work the next day and get caught
up in the petty stuff again but but
somehow it lands right yeah I think that
that that's a beautiful encapsulation of
the reality of the quote/unquote moment
you know which is the name of your
podcast you're super interested in these
sort of transformative you know moments
in time in which people change their
lives but they're not necessarily
crystallized to you know these you know
these episodic things they percolate up
over time with signals and the the the
process is really one of more paying
attention to them and taking tiny little
actions over time that aggregate and
accumulate to what then becomes like the
moment that everyone wants to talk about
yeah I agree with you I also spent a lot
of time afterwards trying to collapse
the time those processes but that's part
of what like we were talking joking on
the way walking into this room about how
our morning routine basically yes so
complex it takes a leg they go into the
afternoon but the idea right if you're
if you're trying somehow to to unify
your thoughts and actions and you're
trying to become comfortable in your
skin I have found for me anyway
finding ways to check in on a more
regular basis in an organized way
an orderly way a routine way makes a
gigantic difference so once I started
journaling everyday which is the thing
that I did started doing at 30 was
morning pages as Julia Cameron describes
in the artists way and I'm glad to the
opportunity took just a tiny bit more
about it I'm sure I know other people
have mentioned it on the podcast but on
Twitter often people will ask me this
question you know I'm super active
they're answering questions for people
and I'll say - morning pages the way
Julia Cameron describes but what Julia
Cameron described and you should go get
her book the artists way if you're
somebody who feels like you're at a
creative roadblock but you know it's
three long hand pages first thing in the
morning
and I do them every day I've done them
every day since you know 1996 I've
probably missed seven days maybe I've
got some days do you ever go back and
read them keep them you read them you're
supposed to do is like maybe read them
five years later not before she says not
before five years I did it like the
first bunch of years I went back and
it's incredible the stuff I started
writing in the beginning about what I'd
hoped would happen all happened you know
and it's not just the regular goal
setting but it was sort of taking myself
what happens when you do morning pages
is in the beginning it's very scary and
very difficult you're just gonna keep
your pen moving you're not allowed to
think you know that I'd be a
perfectionist so for an a tedious
perfectionist like me because that was
the other side of it there was ADHD and
then when I would write I would want it
to be genius if I would I would have
such standards that nobody could hit and
certainly that my intellect was not
capable of hitting so I had to through
the morning pages get comfortable which
was producing pages every day then when
you could comfortable with that and
you're not gonna read them so there's no
stakes
there's no stakes right what happens
after a couple months is you can't
you're sitting there bored because you
got to move the pen for three pages and
you start telling yourself the truth and
you start asking yourself the really
important questions that's not thank you
the target of the thing and you can't go
into a trying to do that because the
whole idea is just to dump your
subconscious onto the page just to write
whatever the [ __ ] comes in your mind but
for me what always happens is eventually
I see the truth on the page and I see
who I'm supposed to be and I see the
ways I'm letting myself down and I see
the ways in which I'm allowing emotions
to rule me and or something happened
that / that forces me to take action you
know and that but so but so what happens
is if I would have been doing morning
pages when the Counting Crows thing
happened that whole next couple of weeks
it would have come back right a couple
days I would have checked in on that
moment it just would have happened I
know it I would have started to go
deeper into it and perhaps I would have
especially if I had also been meditating
then which I wasn't I think I would have
more quickly been able to go oh
something's wrong in a bigger way and I
have to yeah because you would have been
integrated in mind body and spirit yeah
I think you know my experience I started
doing morning pages the artists way in
96 yeah 19 yeah 1996 that's the same
year I still is it yeah right when I got
out of rehab a broken soul and I was
like I don't know what I'm doing you
know and and I can't say that I've had
the fidelity to it that you have I go in
spurts and I find myself always coming
back to it when I feel stuck and usually
those first two pages are you know I
don't know why I'm doing this why am I
writing this and then at about page two
and a half even if it's just one thought
or sentence it makes it all worth it and
I went back in read some that I had
written in like 2009 and I had that same
experience I was like all these things
that I was struggling with but I wasn't
sure about they've all come to pass and
I think it's an exercise in in adherence
to process and being completely in
acceptance and not attached to results
because it's not a results-driven thing
it's about just giving yourself over to
something for the purpose of trying to
connect yourself with yourself in a
better way but yes and I think both of
us are it's funny you look back and and
I find that I can sound to myself a bit
glib about it and so I just want to say
that when I see these creative block
felt like a death
what I mean to say is I was really sad
if I could just say it in simpler
language I was sad and I was I had this
really deep feeling that I wasn't living
up to my potential that there was a
possibility for me to be a better
version of myself now we all have that
all the time right I'm sitting here with
you now and I'm 20 pounds over where I'm
even happy at my fat weight and I know
it could be better in that way but okay
I can look at 20 other areas where I can
I feel I know that I'm checking in and
I'm doing the right thing and I know the
way in which I'm gonna deal with weight
I've done it before but at that time and
at various times when I've been really
low when I've been sad when I felt it
and it's always I think the feeling
between the gap between where I feel
like I ought to be and where I am and
that doesn't mean in a material way
either right at that time all I meant
for myself was why am I so scared to
write why am I so terrified why do I
think I have to put on like a friend a
Parisians you know chapeau and getting a
bunch of pastel paints out in order to
consider myself a creative person but
the fear and sadness and lead leads to
like anger and leads to all sorts of bad
behavior unlike you my only substance
was pizza but it's gonna come out in
some it aberrant behavior or it is and
and so I I just knew I had to like find
tools that I could go back to so the
fidelity of the morning pages yeah I say
10 10 days I haven't done it maybe it's
20 days but it's not more than that
truly not more than 20 days I haven't
done it and all that time because if I
go a day or two days I found I'm just
out of my rhythm and it's hard like
shooting the show makes it really
challenging yeah because I have to get
up so early
so if I can't do them first thing in the
morning because I'm getting picked up at
5:00 a.m. to go to set I will do them at
11:00 in the morning right I'll bring my
journal in my bag and I'll just do them
there and it's not I've been doing it
long enough that I can sink right into
them
mode right even if I've been working a
little bit and and what about the
meditation component speaking of the
protracted morning routine I never miss
it
yeah I I so TM is your that's your vibe
when did you set it about seven years
ago yeah I it was another one of those
moments
it wasn't career based one of my one of
my kids had a health scare and it
they were luckily they were fine perfect
but it was a health scare that lasted a
few days they were hospitalized for a
few days and it looked like it could
have been serious than it wasn't but
after that the the sort of ricochet of
that the long tail of it um really
[ __ ] with me and I became pretty
anxiety ridden and then my mom died and
and a kind of anxiety that I couldn't
fix the ways I normally fixed it in the
past through through um like writing or
through exercise like I would do those
things and I would still feel fear yeah
and so and I'll say I so I took lexapro
for six months because I feel no shame
about I think people for me I think
people should use that stuff when it's
necessary for the shortest window that
they need to get past an acute phase and
then as long as they're pharmacologist
tells them they should but after about
six months I said to the shrink I'd like
to try I'd like to get off of this and I
did and I was fine and the next time
anxiety crept up I decided to try a
different mode yeah and I went and
luckily I got hooked up with Bob Roth
who runs how cool the work yeah yeah Bob
so I got hooked up with Bobby and he
taught me to meditate and so and that
was like I say seven or eight years ago
and I'd say on that one it's even better
than the morning pages I mean I never
ever miss a morning meditation I do
sometimes miss the afternoon meditation
but I feel shitty when I miss it and I
feel great when I do it
and it's I mean even just if for no
other reason than that's 40 minutes
during the day it's 20 in the morning 20
in the afternoon when I'm not online
when I'm not talking to anybody else
when I have to go inward when I have to
quiet my mind or let my mind race but I
can't do anything about it I can't talk
it out I can't write it out I have to
just live in it mm-hmm
and I I just find it insanely incredibly
valuable it's interesting that you
strike me as somebody who you make a
decision to do something and then you do
it like the fact that you've been so
consistent in those two disciplines
alone I think oh it's the opposite I'll
walk the [ __ ] away from something that
doesn't work the quickest aha if
something sticks it's cuz it's giving me
great value like I will I will if I
tried something and I didn't get I've
tried a million things and didn't get
value out of them or I didn't dig it I
just would walk away I would say that's
one of the other like lucky keys in my
life and part of that this does have to
do with like a bunch of privilege things
but like that I have always been
relatively financially comfortable I do
very little that I don't want to do yeah
but but very meditation and warning
pages aren't exactly instant
gratification disciplines in terms of
gauging like is this working or is it
not well but within a month of doing
meditation I felt because the part that
bothered me but the anxiety wasn't just
the thoughts it was that I had a lot of
physical manifestations you know um
people have a lot of physical
manifestations of anxiety like your
stomach can bother you have back pain
like all sorts of I had a lot of
physical stuff that just really very
quickly like went 40% away and then by a
month and a half into meditating want to
be like 80 percent or something like
that where all the the way in which my
heart would raise all the physical stuff
just [ __ ] went away that was easy for
me to want to continue but I mean you're
talking about someone who could go to
the gym for three months
four times a week and then one day wake
up and be like yeah no yeah so I've
abandoned plenty of things yeah because
that does work yeah no I know that works
yeah but I could just be like I can't
it's cold like you know it's cold
outside and
I just can't quite find my way there so
no I don't I'm not I'll say you know our
online personas and our personas on
podcasts I I don't haven't said this
before but it's really important to say
which is in real life I really try hard
to be the person I am on my podcast but
I'm not always yeah I so like I don't
want to present like now I don't follow
through all the time on everything like
I [ __ ] off like everybody else does and
I can get short-tempered like everybody
else does and all the rest of it I
aspire to be somebody who's constantly
chasing this kind of unity and peace and
contribution to the world and I do it
all the time but I'm I'm certainly
nowhere near perfected or nowhere near
actualized in the ways you haven't
graduated from the human condition oh
man I really oh [ __ ] that's you know of
course I'm in the same boat with that
and and it goes back to that permission
piece it's like giving people permission
to express themselves and also to be
innately human with their flaws and
their weaknesses yes but that but
becoming really comfortable in our own
skin
that's what I've now sort of like turn
my attention to is how is acceptance I
agree with you like accepting the human
condition but beyond that finding a way
to be comfortable enough with who we are
that we can be really kind to everybody
else yeah that because the more you're
comfortable with who you are the few err
hang-ups you allow yourself to have the
more you can just present not the
Instagram version of you but you the
easier it is to be empathetic to other
people the easier it is to show that
that empathy for other people the easier
it is to engage and find people where
they are and that's something that's
really challenging and I am constantly
and I you know in a battle to to find
you find moments of grace right but most
of life is hard right but that's
beautifully put and I think that is you
know that's it's a laudable goal it can
you be the same person in every context
like one of them out
you know I've had to climb it's just
being a classic people pleaser where I
would chameleon myself depending upon
the scenario or the situation that I'm
in and it's been a journey of just
getting comfortable enough with Who I am
that it's okay and that the person I am
presenting on the podcast even though
it's about the guests
you know it's my show is the same person
who's going to talk to you if I bump
into you on the street or whatever
context and the person who you know gets
into a road rage incident you know
whatever happens you know in the course
of the day Seth Godin is a genius edit
he's I don't know if if you had Seth in
the pond no I I tried to get him on once
and then I was gonna go up to hit I was
in New York and I was gonna have to go
up to his house to do is worth its
weight so I do anyway I'll make up
points it worth doing yeah I listen to
the recent one that you just did with
him but he's exactly the saw he's one of
my really close friends and he's exactly
the guy he's really like the Buddha in
real life and it's amazing cuz I've seen
him in little many contexts it's just
who he is all the time is he super
dapper all the time
yeah he's put yeah that kind of success
in sort of like their just presents
himself as you imagined that he would
present himself I want to say it doesn't
mean you want to be a person who's run
over either right because that's another
default some people go to like you said
people please are where they want to be
just only nice all the time I'm not I'm
talking about trying to find a way to
understand who you are at a primal way
and be comfortable with that and then
work with that material to be as kind
and good as you can within the context
of living your life and going after what
you want to go after yeah and this is
not the struggle of the artist this is
the struggle of the human every human
being and I think it's fair to say that
we're in an epidemic of people who are
so disconnected from their highest self
or the best version of who they could be
because life's hard man and people are
trying to just pay the bills and they
look at that pursuit as a luxury that's
not available to them I think that's
exactly right yeah so let's go back to
the moment you make this decision that
you're gonna take a stab at this writing
thing so leading up to that was
warning pages work played a part in that
and this friendship with David yeah so
how does this like sort of come together
well if I paint a full picture where I
was I guess Sammy was born when I warm
months left to being 29 or something
like that yeah so I I turned 30 I was
playing a lot of poker then my wife
threw this poker this party and that's
the other thing I'll say a podcast
episode of mine that everybody
gravitates towards is the one I did with
my wife Amy and it's she's incredible
novelist and um she really recognized
this stuff in me before I did that I
could do this it was really clearly
leading me there but um she threw his
poker party for me with all my closest
friends and my little boy was there on
my lap at four months old and I had this
certain kind of a hollow feeling and
poker party because I'd really been
playing a lot of poker I would go my job
at the time was in the record business
was to go out and see bands and in
between seen bands I would go to this
poker club and then during the day
sometimes I would take phone calls at
the poker club and I'm meeting to the
poke Club and I was really into this
life of playing cards I loved a lot of
stuff about it and played cards all
through law school and like the
character and the movie does but then
there was this one moment where I was in
my office during this time after that
party because I did have the note I did
have the notion at the party I didn't
just feel this way but I noted it and I
mentioned it to Amy afterwards and the
reason I brought up Amy is to say
finding surrounding yourself with people
who want the best for you is also not
just is it can be a talent but it can
also be something that you focus on and
it's crucial to focus on it right like
we're just coming out of the holidays
and one of the things I said online that
got something the biggest reaction if I
anything I've ever said online was I I
just I I said to people that if you're
going home for the holidays be really
careful about telling your treehouse to
the people at dinner because they won't
mean to crush your dreams but often
they'll say something that sounds
different to you but
your relationship with them then you
meant then they meant but it can derail
you yeah and pretty sure i retweeted
that okay yeah protect you know protect
yourself in those situations around
yourself with the right tribe yourself
the right people um and so I was
surrounded by the right people and that
made a gigantic difference uh to me but
I was in in my office one night I had
never been a cigarette smoker had never
smoked a cigarette in my life and I was
smoking cigarettes I had smoked for
about four months and I hated cigarettes
was opposed to them got through college
high school without millions of concerts
without ever smoking even one cigarette
and suddenly I'm a [ __ ] cigarette
smoker and I'm eating like a bacon
cheeseburger and I'm supposed to be
listening to all these demo tapes and I
suddenly catch myself with the cigarette
the bacon cheeseburger a big box of
tapes I don't want to listen to and I
did have the crystallized thought then
this isn't the life I'm supposed to be
living and I can't I can't be this
miserable in the work environment I have
I have this wife that I genuinely loved
and that was and this kid that I
genuinely loved and then we had a second
kid who I can't imagine loving anymore
and I went to Dave who was bartending
and he had been trying to be a writer
he'd been riding in bartending and I
went to him and I said and I have to
give credit to Tony Robbins too I found
that time I read awake in the giant with
it uh-huh and it had a gem packed on me
because it allowed me to start doing
some goal-setting this is before the
artists way and through doing awaken the
giant within I realized it was one of
those things like pay attention how
you're feeling
pay attention notice what makes notice
the things that are working notice the
things that aren't don't be afraid to
change so I was I had done that stuff
not the NLP part of it so much but the
sort of look at your life look at the
distance between where you want to be
where you are I had given that book to
David then I so I go to him this night
and I say dude I'm I'm getting the point
where I have to figure out how to write
something I can't what do I do and he
gave me the artist way and I started
doing the morning pages and then soon
thereafter I walked into this poker
in New York called the Mayfair Club and
called him and said I know what the
movie is and he said I'll write it with
you we'll write it together and and so
we we decided and then this is one of
those things I mean David had this
incredible work ethic and didn't have
any of the ADHD issues and didn't have
any of the sort of exact kind of
insecurities that I did in that area and
and he said well we'll do it but we have
to meet every day and we haven't do this
like it's a job and so we worked we met
when he would get done bartending and
before I would go to work Amy cleared
out there was a storage space that every
apartment or a building had one little
tiny storage space had a slop sink in it
room for one chair and Dave and I went
to that room every day five days or six
days a week from when we decided to
start we went for two hours that was it
because I had to go to work
so two hours in the morning we wrote
rounders in four and a half months Wow
four and a half months we've researched
it I mean I'm that's only part of the
time when I'm collapsing is we had Reece
we've researched for a little while so
we would go out go to the clubs and we
would meet and outline it but from the
from the moment we said let's write the
screenplay let's start writing dialogue
four and a half months later we had this
woman and the next chapter of that isn't
oh it's sold and got made right away
there's a whole saga that gets built
into that the movie ultimately gets made
but then it doesn't it's not the sensi
like we look at that movie now and it's
beloved you know I just listened to the
rewatchable z-- episode with Bill and
and it was so it's just it's revered and
one of the questions that they asked and
kind of ponder in that conversation is
like why is this movie so rewatchable
like trying to like deconstruct it and
there's so many reasons for that but the
truth is it is incredibly rewatchable it
is beloved it found its you know legs in
DVD and you know these sort of
technologies that came online but it
didn't happen in an instant for you know
it was a failure at the box office and
it was did okay critically and it was a
fresh tomato but barely but well first
it was rejected by every agency in town
and I I don't
update my blog really by have a blog and
on there
branch off McCallum I tell the whole
story of how it was rejected but all the
agencies in town rejected it it was an
incredibly great lesson to me about
gatekeepers and not not knowing anything
I wrote down everything that they said
and then the day after it's sold
literally like in a movie the day after
it sold all the same agents who rejected
it called to sign us and I said to all
these agents like worse I said the truth
I was young enough that I was just like
dude you said it was overwritten you
said it was underwritten I don't know
what those terms mean still and then
they would all say no it was my
assistant no it was the reader they all
this [ __ ] but I Dave and I knew
right then well you know we have to be
really careful about listening to what
these people say from here on out
because they clearly don't have any
backbone and they don't believe the
things that they say so it sells we in
this part is incredible we get to be on
set every day we were part of making the
movie and then we're in that business
then that's the life we're like I do
want to say one thing which is I didn't
quit my job so often and Jon Acuff has
written about this beautifully I think
in a couple of his books you don't have
to quit your job
you can find a half hour a day and even
if you think you can't find a half hour
day you can mm-hmm I'm not one of those
people says you don't need sleep like
you definitely need to sleep but you
don't need the extra hour online you
don't need the time playing a video game
you don't need the time at that you're
at the time that you're gonna get in
your car drive to Starbucks drive to
wherever else that's 20 minutes that you
could sit and write something and if the
writing is not your thing at cinnamons
you could be taking photographs or
that's 20 minutes that you could be
working there are 20 minutes in the day
and those 20 minutes add up I say to
writers who ask me I say if you write
one page a day one page a day of a
screenplay a screenplay is 100 pages you
can write three finished screenplays in
a year at one page a day a novel you
could finish a novel in a year one page
a day so anyone can write one page a day
and you don't have to turn your whole
life upside down because the catharsis
here's and here's the problem with
quitting it's not just the pressure you
put on yourself which you do it's you
can you convince yourself you've
actually taken action but you haven't
yeah right
quitting walking away
is very dramatic and it might actually
fill you with endorphins
and you might feel like you did
something and you can tell people you
did something but you didn't actually do
anything that's right you just made it
worse
and because human psychology is so
strange the fact that you what you just
talked about is an incredibly doable
thing right and people don't want to
hear that it's so near that because
that's scary because that means that
they could actually do it yes they like
to say well I can't quit my job so I
can't be like you and that's comfortable
and I think that keeps people stuck
totally completely you're completely
right I think a cop's book to quit I
think quitter is the one where he talks
about this really well
where he talks about the way in which
you don't have I wish I would have had
that book when I was young that book and
Steve pressfield's book I wish it would
I had and I was starting out you know
war la revoir it's the best those yeah I
wish I had that then because what I did
you know what I learned to do
essentially was keep the resistance at
bay and that's whatever your pursuit is
if you can just find a half hour where
you don't judge yourself because that's
what you were talking about rich it's
much easier to say I can't find the time
then I'm scared I won't be any good so
instead don't worry about whether you're
good or not
just worry about to find success is a
Tony Robbins thing but I think it's
great it's like you decide how you want
to start Sony Robbins thing and I think
it's great because I save and I
executive-produced I'm I'm not your guru
that movie about Tony and I'm kind of
all in on on his work but one of the
great things he says is is is that you
can define what a successful day is so
if I decide a successful day is I'm
gonna do morning pages I'm gonna write
I'm gonna take a three mile walk if I've
completed those things I've had a
successful day yeah and so lowering it
is empowering and so if you sell
yourself and then you mean it if I spent
20 minutes chasing that whatever X is
but because I know that thanks sort of
the popular there are many books and
podcasts that have come out over the
last bunch of years about how this idea
of chasing your passion is foolish in
fact that that there's no reason that
that giving that advice to young kids
sets them up for failure but I think
that's because we
forget to say the other part of it which
is well we have to work with incredible
rigor to achieve it working with rigor
to achieve something is never a waste of
time because what you've learned at the
end of that is how to work with rigor
and you can apply that to the next thing
that you want to do but working with
rigor parts real hard that took me years
to figure out how to do because not
because I was lazy but because I was
scared scared of failing scared of not
being as smart as I thought I was not
being as good as I thought I was scared
being rejected scared of looking like a
fool
and so but what you find if you do the
work every day you don't actually care
about that stuff anymore because you
know in a hundred days you'll have a
hundred page right but processing rigor
is not sexy we don't talk enough about
that because we want to talk about the
life hack or what's behind that velvet
rope or download this program and this
is gonna solve your problem wait but
what people but you're right the thing
that I fear most people who want to make
a change don't know is that even for
those of us who've made the change it's
still hard every day every day that you
have to write or every day that you have
to find a way to do your show or you
have to stay on your diet which I know
is easy from and I've read all the stuff
I know why it's easy for you but it's
it's believe me I have many challenges
right we but that we still we've just
taught ourselves how to show up every
day we just had to actually put a
practice in place we've put guard rails
up for ourselves but it I could easily
not right I could easily fall into
feeling you know way after the artists
way I had way after I started becoming a
professional writer I had huge career
down swings and it was terrifying to me
and it would have been so easy to not
just easy like I could just see myself
sliding into well this is over well this
was a good run well but because I had a
practice in place I could revert to it
and I apply myself the guardrails thing
is huge and I think making it super
simple almost binary is super important
so whether it's like okay two hours
before work every day or morning pages
are non
like when I changed my diet it started
with alright well I'm just not gonna eat
like meat and dairy like that's just off
the table like it's it's it's it's not
even a sentence it's it's easy to
understand and easy to follow and it's a
rule right it's a guardrail and I think
the more guardrails you establish and
set up that brings structure to that
process and a framework that makes it
easier to execute on the process change
feels cataclysmic especially change that
and it's vague you know ways that also
also all of us right it's totally big
also all of us have when you're on one
side of the thing it's easy to think
that those who've succeeded at any of
this stuff had something special but
that's special and and looks f-code and
i went deep on this podcast because I
bring up Bob Dylan a lot who I do think
is special Bob Dylan he took issue with
that yeah well we had a long talk about
it but for me but but I don't find it
disempowering to think that Bob Dylan is
so yes I believe there are I'm an
atheist but you know in the Jewish
religion there are 36 limit above 36
holy people who walk the earth they
don't even know they are that but they
are that but but the way I would use
that is yeah there are some people who
have extraordinary natural gifts I've
had the opportunity to meet mark Teixera
the great baseball player and and I've
heard him say you know when I was seven
years old I could just turn on a
baseball and I hit the leather off the
ball I was just born with this but
that's not most that's not most
extraordinarily successful people and
they are Phelps either right you know
that guy had to show up for five hours a
day every single day so 12 years so yet
you might not be able to be Bob Dylan I
might never be able to be David Mamet
but I can be it doesn't matter I can
still find a way if I show up every day
to get the best out of my own point of
view of the world out of my own facility
with language and telling stories and
pictures and so but but I fail all the
time
and that's part of what I always want to
be able to communicate with people to
people is the most successful people
most of the most successful people that
you
look at and I'm not including myself in
that category of most successful people
but most people doing the thing that you
wish you were doing are having hard days
doing it all the time they've just
trained themselves to do it yeah back to
the permission yeah give yourself
permission to do this work I was at an
event a couple weeks ago at Largo in LA
and it was a live event with Rob bailed
you know Rob Ellis the keto guy no no I
was like a former mega church pastor oh
no I don't know who's now become sort of
a heretic in the Christian community but
is an incredible public speaker and
unlike a really beautiful guy but he was
doing this live event with Elizabeth
Gilbert and and somehow it came up I
don't whether he asked her or somebody
in the audience asked her like how do
you describe what you do or what is it
that's what is your mission or what's
important about what you do and she said
I'm the person that gives people
permission and then she asked somebody
from the crowd to get up and say what do
you need permission to to volunteer
she's like I give you permission to do
that and it's so freeing from somebody
of that you know how you successful in
that regard whether it's you or her or
somebody like that to say it's okay I
talked about that a lot when I was doing
the vine series that I did where I was
really talking about that you don't have
to happen nobody has to give your
permission to do the work that you want
to do and in this you know our friend
James ol teacher would say all these
gatekeepers have now gone away you're in
an industry where they're still
gatekeepers because just by the nature
of how that industry works but in so
many industries those gatekeepers are no
longer either there or important and so
with that being removed that excuse is
no longer valid and again it goes back
to that's that's that's frightening for
a lot of people or it's empowering
depending upon your perspective well
yeah
it's scary because then you only have a
way it's carries if you then frame it
that you only have yourself to blame
right and if you think well this is my
one shot and if I fail now it means I'm
worthless
and and and one of the you know often
it's because
there was someone when we were young who
told us something about ourselves that
we unfortunately believed and that by
doing and failing we're going to
reaffirm that bad judgment so what you
have to do now my language just try to
figure out what that is and who that was
and how to just silence that voice yeah
it's beautifully here you say that
because when I watch billions which I
love goes without saying I mean oh it's
so it's so well crafted and there's such
a precision to it that it's easy to look
at that and say well whoever's behind
this man these guys are like next level
I can't even wrap my head around what it
would take to construct that universe in
that way well what we are is working
professionals and I'm also not gonna
pour math it right Dave and I've worked
really hard for a really long time to
become really good at doing what we do
and you're in the middle of production
right now still right yeah I'm right as
I was writing here yeah I was I left
this couch that I like to write on to
come here
yeah we've shot we're shooting the
middle of shooting episode 8 of 12 of
season 4 and the trailer just came out
and you can find it if you go to my
Twitter at Brian compliment you'll
you'll see you'll link to the trailer
but we we're good at what we do because
we've like we've worked incredibly hard
at it but we've also tried to like be
really careful about continuing to grow
continuing to learn best practices can
seem to ask questions of great
filmmakers so we'll show our work to
people who we feel like are further
along we'll ask them questions about it
we will grind and grind and grind to
make the thing appear effortless and
grain like it just swings you know we're
we're we're lifelong obsessive
obsessives about this and you know I
also yeah I don't to make it sound like
I just one day decided oh I should be I
should create things I should tell
stories at shifty movies like I had
memorized me when I would was at college
and I would go see a movie like she's
got a habit by Spike Lee or raising
Arizona by the Coen brothers I would see
this in movies three four or five times
I would memorize the movies before you
would just easily have it
BHS by then you could also they would
come out six months later and I've just
watched over and over and I would
memorize them and I would really think
about the language and I would adopt
that language for myself and so like in
94 when pulp fiction came out Amy and I
went to that tonight it came out and
something exploded in my brain here was
a guy was clearly doing everything that
I somewhere deep inside me secretly
wanted to do this right 93 was counting
crows and 94 I saw Pulp Fiction that was
another one of those things where it was
like well you could do anything like you
could make that rectangle on the screen
happen in the middle of you know when
Emma draws the rectangle you break all
those rules and something else kind of
like fired in my brain that made me
become aware of it and Dave and I have
continued one of the great lessons I
took from that Counting Crows thing a
guy a very successful guy very very
successful guy wrote me yesterday on
Twitter and he said hey I have a
question for you do you get angry and
jealous when someone else succeeds yeah
when you see someone got a show and I
said no dude no like I'd be a lunatic if
I felt that way now and I was thinking
that when you were describing Pulp
Fiction I was wondering whether it made
you angry well that was before I'd ever
written anything so you all everything
then made me feel no just made me it all
just made me feel like a failure
uh-huh not angry but know that when Dave
and I wrote rounders early on in it when
I realized we might have a chance at
this I you know I promised myself that I
would never allow the way I felt in the
movies and TV to be like the way I felt
when I was an executive in the music
business somehow that I would never
harden myself to like the beauty of the
art and then I would go in to watch
movies and watch TV shows like a fan the
second or third time I watched something
I'm watching it like a professional but
the first time I watched something
I'm just watching it and I'm just
letting myself get float away on it and
so I still get so turned on when I see
something great that's cool so as long
as you've been in this business and with
all the success that you've had you
still avoided becoming sort of hardened
and yeah if you look at my Twitter
you'll see a lot of negative comments
from me about one thing and one thing
only and that's president United States
there's a lot of that yeah that was
associated with him but I'll never slam
a movie
ever ever I know how hard it is to make
them or a TV show it's too hard yeah
everyone goes into it with the best
intention ever trying to do something
great it's a miracle that anything gets
made yeah it takes it takes some it
takes a litlle qalaat of luck and I
would also say when I mentioned
privilege earlier and I try to say this
all the time and I think it's important
to say it when I looking back at 52 to
be like a white male in America at that
time who didn't have college debt if I
didn't find a way to be successful it
was just entirely my fault the world was
set up for guys like me it was just it
was just laying there for people like me
because nobody knew about subliminal
bias ease in that way so executives
weren't checking themselves on that so
someone like Dave and I walk into a room
we could talk sports with the guys in
charge it was almost always guys in
charge there was a lingua franca that we
shared that made things much easier for
me there was also this idea in the
culture that if you were a guy you could
sort of out dream big and take you shot
in a way that I think women and people
of color felt it was much harder and I
didn't have college debt because my
father was rich enough to pay for
college so I had certain structural
advantages that it's important to say so
you might not be able to spend two hours
a day but so find 20 minutes at first
and and you know the other thing that
happens you gain momentum
suddenly 20 minutes does become an hour
because suddenly that's the part of the
day you look forward to the most that's
part of day where you feel the most
alive I like how you just got really
excited right there what's what have it
on here so what do you think is what
makes a great story what are the
elements of great storytelling uh I
think it's that the storyteller is
incredibly engaged to share that story
with you is died i I don't think until I
I truly don't think intellectually about
storytelling I don't think in terms of
acts like I don't think in terms of
inciting events I never have what I
think about is do I have an incredible
curiosity about this story is there a
world that's incredibly fascinating to
me and today
because we tell each other the stories
right is there a world that's incredibly
fascinating to me or the characters who
I find incredibly compelling is there a
language I start to hear because the
length language has always been a real
key thing for me is there a language
that I I can sort of hear in this in
this universe and then it's just not
faking the funk it's it's not I'll say
I'm much more of an instinctive writer
than I am an intellectual writer and so
I I can tell if something's boring I can
tell if something feels inauthentic or
not real so the environment of the world
but I'm really bad at prescriptive sort
of instruction to people I don't I you
know if I read your script I can tell
you that you have to move this story up
close I can if I read your script I
could take it apart like a professional
but in the abs and by the way I will not
read your script but in me too generally
dumb people but don't send me on your
script don't ask him if founders to is
gonna happen
I mean I've yes we were under suspended
funny I'll make fun of you online on a
very friendly loving sort of a way but
yeah don't send me your script but I
could do that but I don't like really
all the things that we've done think
about billions it's completely
unconventional these yeah these to sort
of leave this third lead in the Wendy
character and then really Taylor who's
also a lead and the way we jumble their
stories together no clear-cut bad guy
never talked about a B and C stories
really I mean once in a while we'll
throw those words around but we're we're
really trying to just make each moment
completely compelling and that the
characters act in ways that are both
true and surprising but there still has
to be this balance between left brain
and right brain because part of this is
a math equation like how do you make all
of these storylines fit together this
puzzle that you have to construct in
order to like tell the story that comes
back well that comes back to rigor for
me anyway that comes back to not when I
say don't fake the funk not lying to
yourself
because if you've listened to stories
and told stories for your whole life you
know when a story works so I don't
actually apply the math in the way that
one might think that I
do I'm aware of it of course because but
I'm aware of it in the way that a
musician is aware of the rhythm of the
two four mm-hmm in a rock song right you
they just start when a musician starts
writing a riff they kind of know what a
riff feels like what a riff sounds like
what the groove how the groove locks and
so yes music musicians have a sort of
innate understanding of math in the same
way that screenwriters do yeah but I
don't think in terms of when I meet
people who say they're great at story
math I'm like I don't understand that I
just like telling stories I don't really
I can't give you the answer that is
there like a like a channel like when
you're running like dialog for example
like are you just getting into you know
some kind of flow state mindset where it
just comes to you from some other place
writing dialogue for me is the most fun
part and it's the part that is the least
conscious it is you know these
characters you are
I know these characters and the
situation oh okay I give you one math
answer the one math answer I can give
you is conflict so there has to be
conflict all the time I would say a
scene works dramatically when someone
wants something and there's an obstacle
that can be an internal obstacle or an
external obstacle so as long as the
dialogue is is engaged in solving a
conflict in getting someone over an
obstacle then you've solved the kind of
story requirement and then that content
it the dialogue really comes from a um I
don't undersell I was a kid who would
form her thinking I said about boring
books they were like radioactive but the
things I liked I would read I read four
books a week but they were just the
books I liked I would read word books
all the time I loved language I always
just wanted to learn vocabulary where
it's not for test I didn't study for the
SATs I just liked reading arcane books
about like language and sentences and I
would memorize movies and so when I
would memorize movies and I could quote
back the dialect to you something became
a need its cellular for me the rhythm of
that kind of speech and the only thing I
ever did
sort of
Chesley is sometimes I will read David
Mamet like when I was younger especially
I would just read David Mamet for to
understand the restraint and rhythm of
his early work yeah are you able to tune
out all the external kind of ephemera
that that is swirling around billions I
mean you know it's so successful last
season was like riveting you're going
into this new season how are you able to
like tune the noise out and just focus
on like trying to do the best
storytelling that you can without being
influenced by you know this this
gigantic enterprise that is this show
now and all the people that love it I
mean David are glad that we're this age
not younger because I none of that I
like it all and I'm fine but you're very
engaged with the fans like you're you're
like a fan yourself the way that you
kind of you know interact with people on
well but you at those conversations
what's the line and Silverado that Kevin
Kline says I decided year either have to
trust everybody or trust nobody it
doesn't make a difference so yeah I the
toys is either to be fully engaged or
not engaged with that with the sort of
with fans and in talking online I'd
rather be in the middle of it we've
already made the show I'll say there's
never been a moment that I'm writing it
but Dave and I are on set shooting it or
editing it that I'm thinking about a
comment anybody made anywhere what
critic or a fan the world of the show is
is its own world and part of being a
working professional is being able to
engage in that way and then shut that
off and engage in the work I mean the
thing lives in our imaginations the two
of us it's it's just these characters
are could no sooner be sort of
influenced by what somebody says in that
way then a character that lives in a
book you read 40 years ago they're their
own thing and their world is its own
world and it seems like the the question
that you're trying to explore with the
show and what's kind of central to it
please correct me if I'm wrong is is
this idea of why is it that
we can get on board with these
characters who are behaving badly and
doing abhorrent things people whose
values seem misplaced who are interested
in power and greed who are very witty
and charming but are not necessarily
behaving you know in their best self so
to speak and not just be on board with
them but be cheering for them like what
does that say about us as humans what
does that say about America and what
does it say about this moment that we're
in right now I mean what it says well I
mean I'm asking you and you're not gonna
answer this question but just in the
asking you know it's my love that's
making us think completely intentional
that you asked the question yeah I mean
uh what I'll say about that is David and
I we definitely made the decision not to
have it in a very conscious way we were
not interested in having a traditional
hero on the show mm-hmm we did not want
a good guy in a bad guy what we wanted
was gray everywhere we wanted to examine
why tremendous verbal gifts a certain
kind of charisma power and money started
to stand in for real qualities of
character in our culture we wanted to
examine why wealth became not just
something to go after not a way to take
care of yourself and your family not a
way to get your dreams but an end in
itself why we are in a country where
people use prosecutorial positions to
advance their own careers we looked
around and saw this so who was popular
in the culture and why meaning why were
I'm friends with Mark Cuban and I've
known him a long time we looked at why
were Mark Cuban and Donald Trump this is
we would sit we're saying this in
interviews before Trump and even
announced he was going to run and I even
then took pains to say I don't consider
mark and
in any way similar other than they were
both one is actually was a successful
businessman that's mark and then the
other was held out to be so and they
were the most two most popular reality
stars in the in the country and so we
asked ourselves why and that was a
backdrop to telling the story Russell
both live David lives in Connecticut I
live in Manhattan and we were around the
hedge fund world and we were here to see
what happened to guys like Eliot Spitzer
on the other side of it chris Christie
people who were supposed to be
prosecutors who used those positions to
advance themselves to become famous to
become powerful and something about it
struck us as incredibly compelling
because these people weren't reviled in
the culture they were celebrated we were
interested in how far people would go
with characters like that and we were
determined not to make either one heroic
you know the first half of the first
season people find themselves rooting
for acts and they don't understand it
and then as acts does these were just
worse and worse things they somehow stay
with them yeah and the same thing for
Chuck and throughout season two and
Wendy and net and Taylor and so yes the
show wants to ask these questions
without giving a direct answer to them
and it's important to see if someone
doesn't watch the show the show super
funny and entertaining yeah that's
really like yeah the main thing is that
people really have a great time watching
it if there's a message underneath it
you can take it or not uh-huh well truth
is stranger than fiction as well because
the question that you're exploring in
the show is being writ large in real
life at the moment on a level that if
you had scripted that ten years ago
people would have said was too extreme
and unbelievable I agree so it is
amazing how you can vacillate between
rooting for axe rooting for chuck and
with the trailer that you just released
you said you're gonna have to choose and
you know throwing Kate into it as well
educate Dylan as Taylor like you're
gonna have to choose and I'm like I
don't know if I want to choose yeah you
can love all you can I
sure I do I'll say David I love all of
them yeah we love all these characters I
mean that's the thing right you can't
you you can't write them if you can't
understand them so I know I I do
understand what they think of themselves
I do understand how they see themselves
in the world my moment with that that I
recollect I mean it's been a while since
I watched last season but the one that's
the moment that stands out for me and I
can't remember it completely
specifically but acts and this other
hedge fund guy I think they were out on
a balcony the other guy was on some hard
times and Acts asked him well how much
money you have or like how much do you
need and I can't remember the figure
with some ungodly amount of millions and
they kind of say well you know that's
not gonna be enough when he explains all
of his expenses so that a guy said that
that wrap I got was in the third episode
last year a guy said that whole rap to
us it was in real a real a real guy that
dinner was walk us through why 50
million dollars it wasn't enough yeah
that's true
the reason why and he really said that
to us about the wife it's 30 million he
really should think to us about that the
the wife is gonna you know you have to
give two million to charities so she
could be on the charity boards and you
gotta have the house out in the Hampton
he said that whole run to us and then we
said to him we're putting that in the
show I said yeah please put it in the
show yeah and after hearing it and
thinking about it for a minute you're
like he's right he can't live he can't
do it he needs more well that's that
wrap and then also I'm gonna use it on
your latter on ax say 300 million is
yeah I mean I watching the show I mean
we hope that people are gonna turn up
while they're watching it maybe you
understand the logic of their thinking
but I do hope that it that afterwards
you will of course think - you know you
will allow yourself to think about what
do you really need yeah and and why and
and what all what that stuff really
means yeah yeah because the fact that I
could hear that speech that exchange and
go oh yeah I can see why he can't live
on fifty million dollars and then take a
beat and
connect with how preposterous that is I
think is is a really poignant reflection
on kind of where we are culturally but
in the same way that that uh you know
Gordon Gekko spawned ungodly thousands
of traders and investment bankers is
this do you have a sense that this show
is having that impact on the hedge fund
industry they all watch those guys are
already in there but like kids in their
college dorm who are now gonna go into
the hedge fund world well we'll see yeah
I I mean I I certainly saw the effect
that rounders had on people wanted to
play poker and how many people that
brought into the game of poker poker
pros to this day will thank us and David
I can't buy ya a meal around them
because they made so much money off of
the what they call the routers fish who
got into it so I do think you know
popular culture the things can't affect
people in that way but that's I have no
idea whether that's gonna happen that's
not true it's probably gonna write well
and beyond that the significance of Asia
Kate Dylan playing Taylor and and having
a transgendered person that is having a
gigantic impact and grass build about
that that's that it's been really cool
awesome to see people react in the
letters Asia gets the letters we get
their remarkable remarkable actor and
the fact that we were lucky enough to
cast a Jenna non-binary actor to play
this gender non-binary character was a
great stroke of fortune it's a privilege
to work with Asia and the effect that
Asia has had is that's something man am
i proud of being a part of that and I
will say I didn't know that was gonna
happen
mm-hmm you never know if something is
gonna catch on and that's what I well
and that's one of the things I'm glad
that there isn't math so if we talk
about how that character came to be each
of my children came home Sam was at
college and Anna was in high school and
within a very short time they each came
home and told me a story about having to
say gender pronouns so they're both
cisgender people but they told stories
of Anna said that every her school was
on a a more frequent than even semester
program
they had these intervals and every eight
weeks or so at each they would start a
new one and the teacher would say has
anyone had a shift and gender or and and
I said so what does that mean and and I
said well you say I'm you announced your
pronouns my pronouns are I thought
that's what do you mean Ted yes'm as a
grown man I couldn't even understand it
right at first time you hear it it
sounds nuts
so then Sammy came back from college and
he said I went to this homeless shelter
to report a story and it's a homeless
shelter for teens and they come and they
announced their pronouns so now I just
heard that twice I went to the writers
room and another writer had had a
similar experience and we started
talking about it and just came up with
this notion of well there should be this
gender non-binary who shows up at acts
capital and then started creating this
character could be a blank slate who we
could think these things about who acts
could see we thought it'd be fascinating
if acts saw himself and someone who from
the outer appearances was so different
from acts but they met in this special
place of their intellect but none of
that was like calculated it was like the
opposite of calculate it was like a fun
thing I heard a fascinating way the
world was changing I thought the stories
really moving when I started reading
about it then we interviewed gender
non-binary people because that's part of
how you do your job you you want to
represent people properly so we had a
few gender non-binary people come to the
writers room and we interviewed them we
spoke to them about it asked about their
lives showed them dialog talked through
it and then we're able to build this
character and then the magic happens
agent Dylan comes walking into the
audition and suddenly the thing just
does life on its own were you
immediately the Asia came and read three
times and each time the character in
Asia started fusing or it was but it was
pretty clear uh-huh did you have a sense
that they would become as important to
the story arc as they ultimately became
because right away oh you did oh right
away well we'd hope the character of
Taylor would do that but also we were
smart enough this is where the sort of
so you're making the art just to make in
the art but I mean after three episodes
we call Showtime and we should we said
you have to make this person a wreck
cast member of the shown you have to
sign this person up and we told you
should we invite an Asian to be a
regular on the series because it was
clear before anyone ever saw it three
episodes in it was like well that's that
person I speak right in the cast like
everybody else right what's the movie
you haven't made yet that you still want
to make what's the story beyond billions
well there are two scripts that Dave and
I have written that have come very close
to getting made that ought to get made
one is called beat the reaper based on a
book by josh pizzelle and the other is
the winter of Frankie Machine based on a
book by Don Winslow's beyond that I
can't say you can't know cuz you don't
know or because you don't want to say
both of you can't talk it out right
right and also sort of what's them I
mean yeah I'm not gonna say yeah are you
gonna tell us anything about what's
gonna happen in billions I mean the
trailer you know we have great new
people on the show this year awesome new
characters and alcove inches back John
Malkovich is in the show just just
awesome for us you know I that that
that's one of this agreed doing this
long enough you know we made two movies
together the beginning of our career
stayed friends not super close to each
other all the time but really all what
never not in touch and so I sent John a
text last year and I said would you come
we have this idea Russian oligarch
you've come to three episodes and he
just immediately wrote back I'd love to
and then his word and did it that's cool
it's awesome well let's wrap this up but
I want to leave people with we covered
it I think pretty comprehensively but
for people that are listening to this
who do feel creatively stuck who feel
like they you know have this voice that
they can't bring expression to beyond
giving permission and creating those
guardrails what's some kind of final
parting well I'm so glad you're here
well first of all I'd say this go easy
on yourself don't add to that
hatred don't add to that yelling at
yourself that you're disappointing
yourself or whoever so take a breath and
understand that it's okay that everybody
who's ever done this has felt what
you're feeling and then find a small
action that you can do consistently do
something to some little thing every day
no everyday sounds like a lot but do it
every day do something every day do
morning pages take a walk where you're
not gonna listen to a podcast or you're
not gonna listen to a book find a way to
be alone with yourself and hear your
voice and nurture that voice in the way
that you secretly know how and and just
do it consistently and know that you do
have 20 minutes 20 minutes you can write
let's say you say I can't write a page
okay write a half a page a day you'll
have written 150 pages in a year and a
year is a really short time and if you
have an iPhone and you think you don't
have enough time go to that little thing
that tells you how much screen time
you've how much time you've spent using
your phone over the last week and I
guarantee you there's an opportunity to
free up I reward myself when I'm writing
if I finish a scene I'll go on Twitter
for 20 minutes then I'll go back and
finish the next scene then you're able
to cut it off at 20 minutes yeah yeah
yeah I like when I get to feel like
again like I said you know I'll be
writing a scene I'll get to where I
think the scenes right a little dopamine
reward uh-huh no award and then back to
work
cool man well thank you so much Brian I
really appreciate the work that you do
and you are like you are kind of like
this self-help guru I mean the advice
that you dispense on these matters is no
small thing I think this is something
that we all struggle with and I'm so
happy to share it because I've took such
advantage of it being shared by people
before me so and the podcast I do is the
only thing I want to direct people to
the moment with Brian Copeland because I
asked these questions to all these
people yeah it's a great it goes well
with your podcast yeah
no it's it dovetails perfectly and you
have fantastic guests I've enjoyed the
podcast for a really long time I don't
know how you find the time to do it well
good show but keep doing it if you can
thanks man all right having me here rich
yeah thanks Brian oh wait
and and I wanna i want to thank my my
niece's boyfriend I'd like to say fiance
if it's not true at this moment my knees
boyfriend Noah who introduced my role
yeah and is in the room right I mean
sweet a rich and said oh you got to
listen this guy he talks about stuff
that you do and you'll love him and
that's what got me interested and you
had asked me to be on this was perfect
timing cuz you'd ask me on the show when
Noah hit right when Noah was telling me
that was cool so it was great the
synchronicity of leg number so I love it
peace glance I take that guy I dig his
work I dig his message everything about
that was just amazing hope you guys
enjoyed it do me a favor let Brian know
what you thought of today's conversation
the guy is a beast on Twitter hit him up
at Brian Koppelman
kop PE l ma n and again season four of
billions returns to Showtime on March
17th so check that out if you're
struggling with your diet if you're
really desiring of mastering your plate
but feel like you don't have a skill in
the kitchen or the time to devote to it
or the culinary acumen you believe you
require I cannot stress enough how much
I know our plant power meal planner can
help you guys it truly is an amazing
product we work very hard to create to
essentially solve a very basic problem
making nutritious eating delicious and
convenient when you sign up at meals
brushroll comm you will get access to
thousands of delicious and easy to
prepare plant based recipes thoroughly
customized based on your personal
preferences with unlimited grocery lists
and grocery delivery in most
metropolitan areas as well as a team of
crack expert nutrition coaches at the
ready to guide you seven days a week you
get all of this for just a dollar ninety
a week literally a cup of coffee so for
more and to sign up go to meals
brushroll comm or click on meal planner
on the top menu on my web so
if you would like to support our work
here at the RRP there are a couple ways
to do just that just tell your friends
about the show or your favorite episode
take a screen grab share it on social
media tag me so I can reshare it
subscribe to the show on Apple podcasts
on Spotify on YouTube all those good
places leave a review on Apple podcasts
very helpful and you can support the
show on patreon at Rich roll com forward
slash donate thank you to everybody who
has done that appreciate everybody who
helped put on the show today I do not do
this alone Jason Kim yellow for audio
engineering production show notes
interstitial music in general
Blake Curtis and Margo Lubin for video
and editing services we did not video
this episode because I did it on the
road but they're the Wizards behind the
YouTube page Jessica Miranda for
graphics David Cohen for advertiser
relationships and theme music as always
by analemma thanks you love you guys see
you back here in a few days with the
iconoclastic pasture and New York Times
bestselling author and live wire
Nadia Boles Weber this one is a treat
you're not going to want to miss it so
until then go out create something
[Music]